The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at OCW.MIT.edu.
JEREMY KEPNER:
All right, well, I
want to thank you all
for coming to what
I have advertised as
the penultimate course
in this lecture series.
Everything else we've
done up to this point
has sort of been
building up to actually
finally really using databases.
And hopefully, you
haven't been too
disappointed at how long I've
led you along here to get
to this point.
But the point being that if you
have certain abstract concepts
in your mind, that once we
get to the database part,
it just feels very
straightforward.
If we do the database piece and
you don't have those concepts,
then you can easily
get distracted
by extraneous information.
So today, there's
no view graphs.
So I'm sure you're all
thrilled about that.
It's going to be
all demos showing
interacting with the actual
technologies that we have here.
And everything I'm showing
is stuff that you can use.
I mean, so everyone
has been-- so I'm just
going to kind of get into this.
And let's just
start with step one.
We're going to be
using the Accumulo
databases that we've set up.
We have a clearinghouse of these
databases on our LLGrid system.
And you can get to that list
by going to this web page
here, dbstatusllgrid.ll.mit.edu.
And when you go there,
it will prompt you
for your one password.
And then it will show
you the databases
that you have access to.
Now, I have access
to all the databases.
But you guys should only
see these class databases
if you log into that.
And so as you see here, we have
five databases that are set up.
These are five independent
instances of Accumulo.
And I started a couple already.
And we can even
take a look at them.
So this is what running
Accumulo instance looks like.
This is its main page here.
And it shows you how
much disk is used,
and the number of tables,
and all that type of stuff.
And it gives you a
nice history that
shows ingest rate over the last
few [INAUDIBLE], and scan rate.
This is all in entries per
second, ingest in megabytes,
all different kinds of really
useful information here.
And you'll see that
this has got the URL
of classdb01.cloud.llgrid.
When I started it, it
was an actual machine
that was allocated to that.
In fact, just for fun here,
I could turn one of these on.
You guys are free to start them.
I wouldn't encourage you
to hit the Stop button,
because if someone
else is using it,
and you hit stop,
then that may not
be something you want to do.
But it's the same set
up-- for instance,
if you have a project,
everyone in the class
can see this because
we've made you
all a part of the class group.
But you can see here
there's other classes.
We have a bioinformatics group.
And they have a
couple of databases.
Those are there.
They're not running right now.
There's a very large
graph database group.
It's running now.
And just to show
this is it's running.
You see this has about
200 gigabytes of data.
And if we look in
the tables here,
we see here we
have a few tables.
Here are some tables with
a few billion entries
that have been put in there.
And this is really what
Accumulo does very, very well.
But I'm going to start one just
for fun here, if that works.
And so it will be starting that.
And all that happens.
And you can see it's starting,
and all those type of stuff.
So we're going to get going here
now with the specific examples.
And I have these.
Just so you know,
today's examples--
so it's in the
Examples directory,
in the Scaling directory,
and two parallel database.
So this is the
directory we're going
to be going through today.
And we have a lot of
examples to get through,
because we're going to be
covering a lot of ground
here about how you can take
advantage of D4M and Accumulo
together here.
So the first thing I'm
going to do is go here.
I'm going to run these.
I have, essentially, two
versions of the code-- one
that's going to do fairly
smaller databases on my laptop.
And then I have
another version that's
sitting in my LLGrid
account that I
can do some bigger things with.
So to get started, we're going
to do this first example PDB01
data test.
So in order to do database
work, and to test data,
we need to generate some data.
And so I'm using a
built-in data generator
that we have called
the Kronecker graph.
It's basically borrowed from a
benchmark called the Graph 500
benchmark.
There's actually a
list called Graph 500.
And I helped write
that benchmark.
And, in fact, I actually-- the
Matlab code on that website
is stuff that I originally
wrote, and other people
have since modified.
And so this is a
graph generator.
It generates a very large power
law graph using a Kronecker
product approach.
And it has a few parameters
here-- a scale parameter,
which is basically the
number of vertices.
So 2 this scale parameter
is approximately the number
of vertices.
So 2 to the 12th gets
you about 4,000 vertices.
It then creates a certain
number of edges per vertex--
so 16 edges per vertex.
And so this computes n max
as 2 to the scale here.
And then the number of edges is
edges per vertex times n max.
This is the maximum
number of edges.
And then it generates this.
And it comes back
with two vectors,
which is just the list
of the-- the first vector
is a list of starting vertices.
And the second vector is
a list of ending vertices.
And we're not really
using any D4M here.
We're just creating a sparse
adjacency matrix of that data,
showing it, and then plotting
the degree distribution.
So if we look at
that figure-- so this
shows the adjacency
matrix of this graph,
start vertex to end vertex.
These Kronecker graphs have this
sort of recursive structure.
And if you kept
zooming in, you would
see that the graph looked like
itself in a recursive way here.
That's what gives us this
power law distribution.
And this is a
relatively small graph.
This particular
data generator is
chosen because you can make
enormous graphs in parallel
very easily, which is something
that if we had to pass around
large data sets every single
time we wanted to test
our software, it
would be prohibitive
because we'd be passing around
gigabytes and terabytes.
And I think the largest
this has ever been run on
is on a scale of 2 to the 37.
So that's trillions of
vertices, or certainly
billions of vertices, almost
trillions of vertices.
And then we do the degree
distribution of this.
And you see here, it creates
a power law distribution.
We have a few vertices
with only one connection.
And we always have a super
node with a lot of connections.
And you can see, actually,
here the Kronecker structure
in this data, which creates
this characteristic sawtooth
pattern.
And there's ways to get
rid of that if you want.
But for our purposes,
having that structure
there, there's no
problem with that.
So this is kind of exactly what
the degree distribution looks
like.
So that's just a small
version to show you
what the data looks like.
Now we're going to
create a bigger version.
So this program, which I'll
now show you-- so this program
creates, essentially,
the same Kronecker graph.
But it's going to
do it eight times.
And one of the nice things
about this generator
is if you just
keep calling this,
it gives you more independent
samples from the same graph.
So we're just creating
a graph that's
got eight times as many
edges as the previous one
just by calling it over
and over again, just
from the random
number generator.
So I have eight.
I'm going to do
this eight times.
And I'm going to save each one
of those to a separate file.
So I create a file name.
I'm actually setting
the random number seed
to be set by the file
name so that I can do this
if I want to-- the seventh file
will always have, essentially,
the same random sequence
regardless of when I run it.
And so I create my vertices.
And I'm going to convert
these to strings,
and then write
these out to files.
And so that's all
that does here.
And one of the things I
do throughout this process
that you will see
is I keep track
of how many edges per second
I'm generating things.
So here, I'm generating
about 150,000.
It varies in terms of the
edges per second here,
but between 30,0000 and 150,000
or 180,000 edges per second,
because when you're creating
a whole data processing
pipeline, that's essentially
the kind of metrics
you're looking-- some
steps might process
your edges extremely quickly.
And other steps might process
your edges more slowly.
And that's, obviously,
the ones where
you want to put more
energy and effort into it.
So we can actually
now go and look.
It stuck it in this
data directory here.
And we just created that.
And so, basically, we write
it out on three files.
Essentially, each one of these
holds one part of a triple-- so
a row, a column, and a value.
So if we look at the
tow, you can just
see it's a sequence of
strings separated by commas,
same with the column, just a
separate sequence of strings
separated by commas.
And then in this
case, the values
we just made all ones,
nothing fancy there.
So now we have eight files.
That's great.
We generated those very quickly.
And now we want to do a
little processing on them.
So if we go pDB03, the first
thing we're going to do
is read those files back in and
construct associative arrays,
because the associative
ray construction
time takes a little time.
And we're going to want to
use it over and over again.
So we might as well
take those triples
and construct them into
associative arrays,
and save them out as
malak binary files.
And now that will
be something that we
can work with very quickly.
So we're going to do that.
So there you go.
It read them in.
And it shows you at the
rate at which it reads them
in, and then essentially
writes them out,
and then gives us
another example
of the edges per second.
And now you see we have Matlab
files for each one of those.
And, not surprisingly,
the Matlab file
is smaller than the three
input triples that it gave.
So this is a 24
kilobyte Matlab file.
And it was probably about
80 kilobytes of input data.
And that's just because
we've compressed all the row
keys into single vectors.
And we have the sparse adjacency
matrix, which stores things.
And so that makes it a
little bit better there.
If we actually look at that
program here-- so we can see
we basically are reading it in.
And then what we're
doing is we're basically
creating an associative array.
We read in each set of triples.
And then the constructor
takes the list
of row strings, column strings.
We just all want this-- since
we knew they were all one,
we were just
letting that be one.
And then there's this optional
fourth argument that tells us,
what do we want to do
if we put in two triples
with the same row and
column, what to do?
The default is it
will just do the min.
So if I have a collision,
it will just do a min.
If I give it this
optional fourth argument
at sum-- in fact, you
can put in essentially
any binary operation there.
But at sum will just
add them together.
So now we'll have-- in
the associative array,
a particular row and column will
have how many that occurred.
And so we're summing
up as we go here.
And then after we create
the associative array,
we save them out to a file.
And so we have that step done.
Now, the whole reason I
showed you this process
is because now I'm actually in
a position I can start doing
computation just on the files.
As I said before, I don't
have to use the database.
If I'm going to do any
kind of calculation that's
going to involve
traversing all the data,
it's going to be faster just
to read in those Matlab files
and do my processing on that.
It's also very easy
to make parallel.
I have a lot of files.
I just have different-- if
I launch a parallel job,
I can just have
different processes
reading separate files.
It will scale very well.
The data array read
rates will be very fast.
Reading these files in parallel
will take much less time
than trying to pull out all the
data from the database again.
So we're going to do a
little analytics here.
pDB04 so I'm going to
basically compute--
I'm going to take those eight
files, read them all in,
and accumulate the
results as we go.
And there we go.
We get to the in
degree distribution
and the out degree
distribution of this result.
If you look to
that program here,
you can see all we did is we
looped over all the files,
just loaded them from in Matlab,
and then basically summed
the rows and added that
to a temp variable,
and summed the columns,
and then plotted them out.
So we just sort of
accumulated them as we went.
This actually-- this
method of just summing
on top of an associative
array is something
that you can certainly do.
It's a very convenient
way to do it.
I should say, though--
and you can kind of
see it here a little bit.
You notice that the
time is beginning
to-- it's not so clear here,
this took so little time.
But on a larger example,
what you would see
is that every single time
we did that-- because we're
building and then adding,
we're basically redoing
the construction process.
And so, eventually, this will
become longer, and longer,
and longer.
And so it's OK for
small stuff to do that,
or if you're only going
to do it a few times.
But if you're going to be
accumulating an enormous amount
of data, then what
we can actually do
is we have another version
of this program pDB04 cat
DegreeTest And you can tell
that was a little bit faster.
You see here it's all
in milliseconds of time.
And this is a little
bit longer program.
What we're doing here
is, basically, we're
reading in-- doing
the exact same thing.
We're loading our Matlab file.
We're doing the sum.
And then since I know something
about the structure of that.
That is, basically
I'm summing the rows.
I can just append that to a
longer list, and then at the
and do one large sum.
And that's, obviously,
much faster.
And so these kind of tricks
you just need to be aware of.
If you're trying to do
very-- people typically
want to do a large
amount of data.
You just do the simple sum.
That will be OK.
But if you're doing a
lot over a large list,
that essentially becomes
almost an n squared operation
with the loop variable.
And this is one that
will be even faster.
You can make it even
faster, because we are
doing this concatenation here.
When you do a concatenation in
Matlab, you're doing a malak.
If you want to make
it even faster,
you can pre-allocate
a large buffer,
and then append and
into that buffer.
And then when you hit
the edge, do a sum then,
and do it that way.
And that's the
fastest you can do.
So these are tricks--
very, very large sums,
you can do them very
quickly, and all with files.
You don't need a database.
And this is the
way to go if you're
going to be doing an
analytic where you really
want to traverse most of
the data in the database,
in your data set.
If you just need to get pieces
of the data in the database,
then the database
will be a better tool.
We did that.
So those show how we
worked with files.
And that's always a
good place to start.
Even if you are working
with the database,
if you find that you're doing
one query over and over again
that you're going to be
then working with that data,
a lot times better to
just do that query,
and then save those results
to a file, and then just work
with that file while
you're doing it.
And, again, this is
something that people often
do in our business.
Now we're going to get to the
actual database part of it.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is we have to set
up our database.
So we're going to create
some tables in Accumulo.
And so we want to
create those first
so they're created properly.
And so I'm going to show you
the program that does that.
The first thing that
you're going to do,
it's going to call
a DB setup command.
And so let me-- this program,
I'm going to now show you that.
And so when you
run these examples,
you will have to modify
this DB setup program.
So the first thing
you'll notice is
that we're all using the
same-- each group that's
with those databases is
all using one user account.
And you can say, well, that's
not the best way to do it.
Well, it's very consistent
with the group structure,
in that it's basically
you're all users.
The database is there to
share data amongst your group.
And so it is not an
uncommon practice
to have a single user account
in which you put that data.
So we have a bit of
a namespace problem.
If you all just ran
this example together,
you'd all create the exact
same table, and all fill it up.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is just pre-pend the tables.
And I would suggest that
you put your name-- instead
of having my name there,
you put your name there.
And then we have
a special command
you're called DB Setup LLGrid,
which basically creates
a binding to a database just
using the name of the database.
So it's a special function.
That's not a generic function.
It only works with
our LLGrid system.
And it only works if you have
mounted the LLGrid file system.
So hide all this stuff
here, get rid of that.
So as you see here, I have
mounted the yellow grid file
system.
And you need to do that because
the DB setup command, when
it binds to the
database it actually
goes get the keys from
the LLGrid file system.
And those keys are sitting in
the group directory for that.
So, basically, from a password
management perspective,
all we need to do is
add you to the group.
And then you have
access to the database.
Or if we remove
you from the group,
you no longer have
access to the database.
So that's how we
do-- otherwise, we'd
have to distribute keys to
every single user all the time.
And so this is why we do that.
So this greatly simplifies it.
But you will not be able
to make a connection to one
of these databases unless
you are either logged
into your LLGrid account.
Or if you are on your computer,
you've mounted the file system,
and D4M knows where
to look for the keys
when you pass in
that setup command.
So if we look at that again--
and this is just a shorthand
for the full DB server command.
So if you were connecting to
some database directly other
than one of these--
or you could even
do it with these-- you
would have to pass in,
essentially, a five
argument thing,
which is the hostname of
the computer and the port,
the name of the instance,
the name of the-- I
guess there's a couple instance
names here-- and then the name
of the user, and then
an actual password.
And so that's the generic
way to connect in general.
But for of those of you
connected to LLGrid,
we can just use this
shorthand, which is very nice.
Then we're going to
build a couple of tables.
So we have these--
first thing we're
going to do is we're going to
want to create a table that's
going to hold that adjacency
matrix that I just created
with the files.
And so we're going to do
that with a database pair.
So if we have our
database object here
and we give it two
string names, it
will know to create two
tables in the database,
and return a binding to that
table that's a transposed pair.
So whenever we do an
insert into that table,
it will insert the row and
the column in one table,
and then flip those and
insert the column and the row
in the other table.
And then whenever
you do a lookup,
it will know if it's doing a
row lookup to look on one table,
and if it's doing a
column lookup to do it
on the other table.
And this allows you to do
fast lookups of both rows
and columns and makes
it all nice for you.
We're also going to
want to take advantage
of Accumulo's built-in
ability to sum as we insert.
And so we're going to
create something that's
going to hold the degree as
we go-- very useful to have
these statistics,
because a lot of times
you want to look up something.
But the first thing
you want to do
is to see, well, how many
of them are in there?
And so if you
create, essentially,
a column vector with that
information, it's very helpful.
Later, we're going
to do something
where we actually store the
raw edges that were created.
So when we create
the adjacency matrix,
we actually lose a little
bit of information.
And so when we create
this edge matrix,
we'll be able to preserve
that matrix, that information.
And, likewise, we'll
be doing the tallies
of the edges in that as well.
So that's what this does.
And that's the setup.
You'll need to modify that
and this program here.
Actually, basically
after the setup is done,
it adds these accumulator things
by designating certain columns
to be what they call combiners.
So in this adjacency
degree table, I've said,
I want to create two new
columns-- an out degree,
in degree column,
and the operation--
that I want to be
applied when there
are collisions on
those values is sum.
It will then sum the values.
And, likewise, with the
edge, since I only have one
I'm going to have to
degree and sum there.
So that's how we do that.
So if we now go to our database
page here-- so you can see,
class DB3, it started.
We can actually view the info.
And this is what a nice,
fresh, never before used
Accumulo instance looks like.
It has very little data.
It has one table, a meta
data table and a trace table.
And there's no
errors or anything
like that-- so a
very clean instance.
So that's what one looks like.
We're going to use one that
we've already started though,
which is DB1.
And if we look at
the tables here,
there's already some tables.
Michelle ran a
practice run on this.
[? Chansup ?] ran
a practice run.
I'm going to now create those
tables by live setup test.
There, it created
all those tables.
You can now see, did
it actually work?
So if I refresh that--
and you can see,
it's now created these six
tables which are empty.
We do have abilities
to set the write
and read permissions
of these tables.
So right now, everyone
has the ability
to read, and write, and
delete everyone else's tables
in a class database.
In a project, that's not such
a difficult thing to manage.
You all know that.
But you could imagine in
a situation [INAUDIBLE],
we had a big ingest.
This is a corpus of data.
We don't want anybody-- we can
actually make the permissions.
We can make it read only so
that no one can delete it.
Or we can make it so it's
still read and write,
but it can't be deleted, whole
cloth, those permissions exist.
A feature we will add
to this database manager
will also be a
checkpoint feature.
So, for instance, if
you did a big ingest,
have a bunch of data that
you're very happy with,
you can checkpoint it.
You'll have to
stop the database.
Then you can create a checkpoint
of that stop database, name
checkpoint.
And then you can restart
from that, if for some reason
your database gets corrupted.
As I like to say, Accumulo,
like all other databases,
is stable for production.
But it can be unstable
for development.
New database users, the
database will train you
in terms of the things that
you should not do to it.
And so over time, you will not
do things that destroy data,
or cause your database
to be very unhappy.
And then you will have a
nice production database,
because you will only do
things that make it happy.
But in that phase
where you're learning,
or you're experimenting
with things, as
with all databases,
any database,
it's easy to do
commands that will
put the database in a
fairly unhappy state, even
to the point of corrupting
or losing the data.
But for the most part, once it's
up and running in production--
and we have a database that's
been running for almost two
years continuously using a very
old version of this software.
So it just continues
to hum away.
It's got billions
of entries in it.
It's running on a single Mac.
And so it definitely, we've seen
situations where it's-- it has
the same stability as just
about any other database.
So now we've created
these tables.
And let's insert
some data into them.
So I do pDB06.
So I'm now going to insert
the adjacency matrix.
And now it's basically
ereading in each file
and ingesting that data.
And it's not a lot of data.
It doesn't take very long.
And now you can see up here
that data is getting ingested.
And you see there.
So we just inserted about 62,000
in each of those two tables,
and 25,000, which for
Accumulo is a trivial amount.
We just inserted 150,000
entries into a database,
which is pretty
impressive, to be
able to do that in, essentially,
the blink of an eye.
And that's really the
real power of Accumulo,
is this-- on a lot of other
databases, 150,000 entries,
you're talking
about a few minutes.
And here, it's just
you wouldn't even
think about doing that twice.
So we can take a
look at that program.
So here we go.
So we had eight files here,
and basically loaded the data.
And, basically, one
thing we have to remember
is that our adjacency
matrix has numeric values
in an associative array.
And Accumulo can
only hold strings.
So we have to call
NumtoString function, which
will convert those numbers
into strings to be stored.
So the first thing we do is we
load our adjacency matrix A.
We convert the numeric
values to strings.
And we just do a put.
So we can just insert the
associative array directly
into the adjacency matrix.
It pulls apart the triples.
And it knows how to
take care of the fact
that it recognizes this is
a transposed table pair.
And it does that ingest for you.
And, likewise, same thing here--
now on these other things,
we pulled it out.
We summed it, convert it to
strings to do the out degree,
and the same thing
to do in degree.
And so this is actually where
the adjacency matrix comes
in very handy because when
we're doing accumulating,
if we didn't first sum
it and then do it--
if we put those raw
triples into insert,
we're essentially redoing
the complete insert.
And so this saves
usually an order
of magnitude in
number of inserts
by basically doing the sum
in our D4M program first,
and then just inserting those
sum values, just a nice way
to save the database a little
bit of trouble in doing that.
And so we certainly recommend
this type of approach
for doing that.
So the next one DB07.
So now we're going to a query.
We're going to get some
data out of that table.
And so what we did
here is we said,
I want to pick 100
random vertices.
So in this case, I randomly
generate 100 random vertices
over the range 1 to 1,000.
OK And I then convert those
to a string, because these
are numeric values.
And I will look up strings.
And then the first
thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to look up
the degrees, essentially,
of those vertices.
So I have my sum table here
called T adjacency degree.
I'm going to pass
those strings in.
And then I'm going to
get just the degrees.
So that's just a big,
long, skinny vector.
Looking things up from
that takes much less time
than looking up whole
rows or columns.
And it stores all
those values for me.
So that's a great
place to start.
And then I want to
say, you know what?
I only care about degrees that
have been a particular range.
This is a very
common thing to do.
There will be vertices that
are so common you're like,
I don't care about those.
I have their tally.
And these are sometimes
called super nodes.
And doing anything with
those is a waste of my time,
and forces me to end up
traversing enormous swathes
of the database.
So I'll set an upper threshold
here and a lower threshold.
So, basically, I take a degree.
I'm just going to look
at the out degree.
And I say, I want things
that are greater than the min
and less than the max.
And I want to get
just those rows.
So that's this query, a
fairly complicated thing,
analytic here done
in just one line.
And now a new set of vertices,
which are just the rows that
satisfy this requirement.
And then I'm going to
look those up again.
So I'm just going to look up
the ones that satisfy those--
now I'm going to get the
whole row of those things.
So before, I was just
looking up their counts.
Now I'm going to
get the whole row.
And I know that
there's none that
have more than this certain
value, or have too few.
And then I'm going to plot it.
And so if we look at the
figure, there we see.
So we ended up finding one,
two, three, four rows that
had between-- these should all
write-- one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, so
that's between five and 10.
These should all be
between five and 10.
And then this shows what
their actual column was.
And so that's a
very quick example
of that kind of analytic.
And, again, real bread
and butter, and this
is basically standard from a
signal processing perspective.
The max is our
clutter threshold.
We don't want that.
It's too bright.
And then we'll have
a noise threshold.
We're like, we
don't care anything
that's below a certain value.
And this sort of narrows
in on the signal.
Same kind of processing
and signal processing,
we're doing it here on graphs.
And Accumulo supports that
very, very nicely for us.
So let's move on to
the next example.
And, actually, if we look here,
if we go back to the overview--
so you see here, that
was that ingest I did.
This is the ingest--
so very quick,
it's getting about
5,000 inserts a second.
That was over a very
short period of time.
It doesn't even time to get
reach its full rise time there.
And then you can
see the scan rate.
And it was very small.
It was a very tiny
amount type of thing.
As we do larger data sets,
you'll really see that.
And this is a great tool here.
It really shows you
what's really going on.
Before you use the database,
always check this page.
If you can't get to the
page of the database,
you're not going to be able
to get to the database.
There's no point in
doing anything with D4M
if this page is not responding.
Likewise, if you look
at this, and you see
this thing is just hamming away.
You're seeing hundreds
of thousands or millions
of inserts a second, it
means that, guess what?
Someone is probably
using your database.
And you might want to either
pick a different database,
or find out who that
is and say, hey,
when are you going to be
done, or something like that?
Likewise, on the scan side.
Likewise, when you do inserts--
you'll get some examples here
of the kinds of rates
you should be seeing.
You want to make sure
you're seeing those rates.
If you're not
seeing those rates,
if you're basically
just using the resource
but only inserting
at a low rate,
then you're actually
doing yourself
and everybody else a disservice.
You're using the database.
But you're using
it inefficiently.
And it's much better to
have your inserts go fast,
because then you're
out of the way.
Your work gets done quicker.
And then you're out of everybody
else's way quicker too.
So I highly recommend
people look at this
to see what's going on.
So I think the
last one was seven.
So we'll move on to eight here.
So now we're going to do
another type of query.
We're going to do a little
bit more sophisticated query
That query used
the degree tables
to sort of prune our query.
So you think about it.
There was probably
an edge in there
that had like 100 entries.
And we just were
able to avoid that,
never had to touch that edge.
But if we had touched
it, that could
have been a much bigger query.
You might be like, well,
100 doesn't sound bad.
Well, it's easy to get
databases where you'll
have some rows with
a million entries,
or columns with a million
entries, or a billion entries.
And you really
don't want to have
to query those rows or
columns, because they will just
send back so much data.
But you can still
have situations
where you're doing
queries that are going
to take-- they're going to send
back a lot of data, more data
that you can really handle
in your memory segment.
So we have a thing
called an iterator.
So we've created an iterator
log to set up a query
and have it work through it.
Now, this table is so
small that you won't really
get to see the
iteration happening.
But I'll show you the setup.
So we'll do that.
So that was very quick.
So, essentially, we're
doing a similar thing.
We're creating a
random set of vertices
here, about 100, creating
over the range 1 to 1,000.
And we're creating an
iterator here called
Tadjacency iterator.
It's this function
here, iterator.
We pass it in the table.
Then we have a flag,
which is element,
which is, how many entries do
we want this iterator-- it's
the chunk size.
How many entries do
we want this iterator
to return every single
time we call it?
And here, we've set max element
to be a pretty small number,
to be 1,000.
So what we're saying is every
single time we do this query,
we want you to return
1,000 at a time.
Now for those of you who
are Matlab aficionados,
you should be in awe,
because Matlab is supposed
to be a stateless language.
And there's nothing more
stateful than an iterator.
And so we have tricked Matlab
with a combination of Matlab
on the surface and some
hidden Java under the covers
to make it have the feel
of Matlab, yet hold state.
So now what we're
going to do is we're
going to-- this just
creates the iterator.
We then initialize the query
by actually passing in a query.
So we now say, OK, the query we
want is over this set of rows
here.
And so we're going to run
the query the first time.
And since that thing
returns string values,
and we want numbers, we
have to do a string to num.
And that's our first
associative array that's
the result of the first query.
We then initialize
our tally here.
And then we just do a
while on this result.
So we're going to say, oh,
if there's something there,
then we want sum that,
and add it to our tally,
to our in degree tally.
And then we call it again.
So we do the next
round of the iteration
by just calling the
object with no argument.
And it will just run it
until the query is empty.
If we put in an argument,
it would re-initialize
the iterator to that new query.
And so you don't have
to create a new iterator
every single time you want
to put in a different query.
You can reuse the object.
Not that it really
matters, but this
is how you get it to do again.
So it's a pretty elegant
syntax for basically doing
an iterator.
And it allows you to deal
with things very nicely.
And as we see here, then we
did the calculation here,
which is all right.
I want it to then return
the value with the largest
maximum degree.
So, basically, I
compute the max.
I get the adjacency
matrix of the degree.
And I compute its maximum.
And then I set that
equal to n degree.
And it tells me that the first
vertex had a degree of 14
in this query,
which makes sense.
In the Kronecker
matrix, 1, 1 is always
the largest and densest value.
So that's just how
we use iterators.
Let us continue on here.
Now I'm going to use iterators
in a more complicated way
to do a join.
So a join is where I want
to basically-- maybe there's
a row in the table.
And I only want
the rows that have
both of a certain
type of value in them.
So, for instance, if I had
a table of network records,
I might like, look, please
only return records that
have this source IP, and are
talking to this domain name.
So we have to figure out how
we do joins in this technology.
So I'm going to do that.
So let me run that.
So join-- so a little
bit more complicated,
obviously, we're building up
fairly complicated analytics
here.
So I create my
iterator limit here.
I'm going to pick two columns
to join, column 1 and column 2.
And this just does a simple
join over those columns.
So basically what
I'm doing is I'm
saying, please return
all the columns that
contain-- this is an or
basically either column 1 or 2.
I'm going to then convert
those values, which
would have been string values
of numerics, to just zeros or 1.
Then I'm going to sum that.
So, basically, I
got the two columns.
I converted all the values to 1.
Now I'm going to
sum them together.
And then I'm going
to ask the question,
where were those equal to 2?
Those show me the records.
So that's what I'm doing here.
I'm saying, those equal to 2.
So that shows me all the records
where that value is equal to 2.
And I can then get the
row of those things,
and then pass that back
in to the original matrix.
And now I will get back
those rows with those things.
And so we can see that.
I think that's the first
figure that we did here.
We go to figure one.
And those show,
basically-- what did we do?
Right.
This shows us the complete
rows of all the records
that had the value 1.
So this is here,
1, and I think it
was 100, which is somewhere
right probably in there.
So basically every single one
of these records had 1 and 100
in it.
And then it shows us all
the rest of the values that
are also in that record.
If we just wanted those
columns and those values,
when we just summed them
equal to 2, we were done.
But this allowed us to then
go back into the record,
and now into the full set,
and just get those records.
So this is a way
to do a join if you
can hold the complete results
of both of those things,
like give me the whole column
1, and the whole column 2.
That's one way to do a join,
perfectly reasonable way
to do a join.
I'm going to now do this
again, but with a column range.
So I'm going to say, I want to
do a join of all columns that
begin with 111, and all
columns that begin with 222.
So that would return more.
I'm going to create two
iterators now to do that.
So I have initialized my
iterator, iterator one
and iterator two.
And so now I'm going to start
the first query iterator here
by giving it its column
range that initializes it.
And I get an A1.
And then I check to
see if A1 is not empty.
If it isn't empty, I'm going to
then sum it, and then call it
again until it proceeds.
And since it's
such a small thing,
it only went through that once.
And then now I'm going to
do the same thing again
with the other iterator and
sum them to get together again.
And now I'm going to
join those two columns.
And that's a way
of doing the join
with essentially two
nested iterators,
and doing the join that way.
So that's something you
can do if you couldn't hold
the whole column in memory
and you wanted to build it up
as you went.
That's a way to do
it with iterators.
Then let's see here.
There's an example of
the results from that.
And just so you know,
when you do an SQL query
in an SQL database, this is what
it's doing under the covers.
It's trying to do whatever
information it can.
It will [INAUDIBLE] hold a
lot of internal statistical
information.
It's trying to figure out, can
I hold the results in memory?
Or can I not?
Do I have to go
through in chunks?
Or do I not?
Do I have information about
oh-- you know, this query,
do I have a sum table sitting
around that will tell me,
oh, which column
should I query first,
because it will
return fewer results?
And then I can go from
there type of thing.
So this is all going
under the covers.
Here, you get the power to do
that directly on the database.
And it's pretty easy to do.
But you do have to
understand these concepts.
So now we'll move on.
So that was all with
the adjacency matrix.
And as I said before, when we
formed the adjacency matrix,
we threw away a
little information,
because if we had multiple-- if
we had a collision of any kind,
we lost the distinctness of
that record, or that edge.
And a lot of times, like, no
we want to keep these edges,
because, yeah, we'll have other
information about those edges.
And we want to keep things.
So we want to store that.
So we're going to now reinsert
the data in the table,
and use, essentially, instead
of an adjacency matrix,
an incidence matrix.
An incidence matrix, every
single row is an edge.
And every single
column is a vertice.
And so an edge can then
connect multiple vertices.
It also allows us
to store essentially
what we call hyper edges.
So if you have an edge that
connects multiple vertices
at the same time,
we can do that.
So let's do that.
This is inserting about
twice as much data.
So it naturally takes a
little bit longer there.
And you see the
edge insertion rates
that we're getting there,
30,000 edges per second.
So let's go and see what
it did to our data here.
So if we look at our
tables, we can see now
that there's our edge data set.
And you see we've inserted
about 270,000 distinct entries
in this data.
So there's the edge table.
And there's this transpose.
And there's the degree count.
And as you saw
before, we had 53,000.
So that just shows you the
additional information.
Let's look at that program here.
So, again, we're looping
over all our files here.
We're reading them in.
I should say, this case
we're reading in the raw text
files again.
We're not reading in
the associative array
because we just want
to insert those edges.
And then the only
thing we've done
is that, basically,
to create our edge we
had to create-- this data
didn't come with a record label.
So we don't have any.
So we're constructing a unique
record label for each edge
here just so that we
have it for the row key.
And then we're pre-pending the
word out into the row string
and in into the column string.
So we know when we
create our record,
out shows the
direction it came from.
And in shows the
direction it left.
And so that's a way
of creating the edge.
And then, likewise, we do
the count degree and such
to preserve that
information so we
can sum the new total
number of counts there.
So let's do some
queries on that.
So I'm going to ask for
100 random vertices here.
So I get my random vertices.
And then I'm going to do
my query of the strings.
But I have to pre-pend this
out, slash, the value in it
so I know I'm looking for
vertices from which the edge is
departing.
And I'm going to
get those edges.
So I get those edges.
So I created the query.
I get the edges.
I'm going to do my
thresholding again.
I want a certain min and max.
And then I'm going
to do the threshold.
So this just gave me
the degree counts.
And I thresholded
between this range.
And then now I then do the same
thing back with the-- I say,
give me everything
greater than degree min
and less than degree max.
I get a new set of rows.
So that will just
return the edges
that are a part of vertices
with these degree range.
And then I'm going to get all
those edges, all the records
that contain those vertices,
through this nested query here.
The result is this.
So, basically, this
shows me all the edges
there are a part of this
random set of vertices
that have a degree range
between five and 10.
This is a fairly
sophisticated analytic.
We're doing about
seven or eight queries
here, doing a lot
of mathematics.
And you see how dense it is.
And, hopefully, from what
we've learned in prior
has some intuition for you.
And we'll continue on.
So now I'm going to do a
query with the iterator--
again, same type of drill.
I set the maximum number of
elements to the iterator.
I get my random set of things.
I create an iterator, again
setting the number of elements.
I initialize the iterator
to be over these vertices.
I then check to see if
it returned anything.
If it did, I'm going
to then actually pass
the rows of that back into it
to get the edges containing
those vertices,
and then do a sum
to compute the in degree,
and so on and so forth.
And then I get here
the maximum in degree
of that set of vertices was 25.
So that's just an
example of that.
And that was 12.
And I think 13 is our last one.
All right, and again, a
more complicated example
showing basically a join
over this space creating,
essentially, a couple
of sets of edges,
a couple of column
ranges, iterators,
and so on and so forth.
And I won't belabor this point.
But this just shows how you
can combine between using
the degree table and iterators.
You have all the
tools at your disposal
that any type of query planning
system would have inside it,
that it would use to
make sure that you're not
over-taxing the results
that you're returning too.
And that's a lot of times if
you do a query on any database,
you get the big spinning
watch or whatever.
It's because the query you
asked was simply too long.
It also gives a
lot of nice places
to-- if you're making a query
system, to interrupt it.
So if you do the query
against the counts,
you can quickly tell the user,
look, you just did a query.
And this is going to
return 10 million results.
Do you want to proceed?
And so you, of
course, [INAUDIBLE].
Or likewise, you can set a
maximum number of iterations.
Like it says, OK, I
want to get them back
in units of 100,000 entries.
But I only want to
go up to a million.
And then I'm going
to pause and get
some kind of additional guidance
from the user to continue.
So those are the
same tools and tricks
that are in any query planner
very elegantly exposed
to you here for managing
these types of queries.
With that, I want
to do some stuff
where we do a little
bit of bigger data sets.
So I've walked
through the examples.
I want to show you what this is
like running on a bigger data.
So let's close all that.
Close that.
I want to do this one.
So now I'm logged
into-- I just SSHed
into classdb02.cloud.
llgrid.ll.mit.edu, which
happens-- it tells you which
node it's actually mapped to,
which is node F-15-11
in our cluster.
And this is a fairly
powerful compute node.
These are our next generation
compute nodes for LLGrid.
So those of you who've
been using LLGrid
for all these past
years, may have
noticed that they're getting
a little long in the tooth.
These are the first
set of the new nodes.
And we'll have about 500 of
them total in various systems.
And so here, I am doing
something a little bit larger.
So let me see here.
Examples-- so I'm on
my LLGrid account here.
And I'm going to
go to 3 and then 2.
Then I do open dots.
So that's the directory.
And so the first thing I
did is in my DB setup here,
you'll notice that I
have done class DB 0.
And also, we don't need to do 1.
But I will do 2 here.
I've made this bigger.
So I have made this now
2 to the 18th vertices,
instead of what I had before.
So let's go [INAUDIBLE] anymore.
So if I do PDB02, it's going
to now generate these things.
And so it's generating
a lot more data.
And you see it's doing at about
200,000 vertices per second.
Just shows you the difference
between the capability
of my laptop and one
of these servers here.
And this will also-- I'm
logged onto this system.
It has 32 cores.
I can do things in parallel.
And so, for instance,
if I did eval p run,
for those of you who have had
the parallel Matlab training,
I can say before.
And since I'm logged
into this node,
and I just do curly
brackets, it just
says launch locally
on that node.
Don't launch onto the grid.
And now it's launching that in
parallel on this node data one,
did that.
Data two, did that.
Now it's done.
And the others finished there
work too, probably right
about now.
So that's just an
example of being
able to do things in parallel.
We've created here-- I
mean, you look at it.
We did eight times 300,000.
We did 2.5 million edges
in that, essentially,
five seconds type of thing.
So multiply this by 4.
You're doing like a
million edges a second just
in that one type of
calculation there.
Move on TBPB03.
And-- oh, I should say, I did
modify that program slightly.
Let's see here.
So if I look at-- the line
labeled in big capital letters
parallel, I uncommented it.
That's what allows each
one of the processors when
they launched to then
work on different files.
Otherwise, they all would
have worked on the same files.
So by uncommenting
that parallel,
this now becomes
a parallel program
that I can run with
evalp run command.
Of course, you have to have
parallel Matlab installed,
which of course you all
do since you're on LLGrid.
But for anyone seeing
this on the internet,
they would need to have that
software installed too, which
is also available on the
web and installable there.
So that's all we
needed to do, was
uncomment that one line to
make that program parallel,
and did the right
thing for us as well.
And we're going to go
on to the next example.
And we did the same thing there.
We just uncommented parallel.
And it's now going to create
these associate arrays
in parallel.
So if I do PDB30-- so it's
now actually constructing
these associate arrays.
You see it takes
about four seconds
to do each one of those.
It's doing about 120,000,
130,000 entries per second.
So this thing will take about 25
seconds to do the whole thing.
And, again, if we ran that
in parallel, it automatically
tries to kill the
last job you ran
if you're in the same
directory so that you're not
[INAUDIBLE] on top of yourself.
And now you see it's
doing that again.
And now it's done.
And the other one
is finished as well.
You can actually check
that, if you really want to.
Just hit Control Z, if I
do more [INAUDIBLE] out.
You can see those for the output
files of each one of them.
I'm not lying.
They didn't take a
ridiculous amount of time.
They all completed.
You always encourage
people to check
those dot out files, and then
that [INAUDIBLE] directory.
That's where it sends
all the standard out
from all the other nodes.
It's probably the
number one feedback
we get from a user who
says, my job didn't run.
We're like, what does it
say in your .out files?
And usually, like, oh
there's an error on node 3
because this calculation is
wrong on that particular node,
or something like that-- so
just reminding folks of that.
Moving on-- so what
did we just do?
We did three.
So we did PDB4, re-test.
And this is doing a little
bit bigger calculation.
And so you can see
here-- I told you
it does begin to
get bigger here.
So it started out--
the first iteration
was about 0.6 seconds.
And then it goes
on to 0.8 seconds.
If we did that cat approach,
it would do it faster.
I'll show you a
little neat trick.
This is also a parallel
program when I run it.
And, basically, I loop
over each file here.
I'm just doing this
little ag thing just
to sync the processors
just for fun so I don't
have to wait for them to start.
And then it's going to go.
And they're going
to do their sums.
And then when they're
all done, they're
going to call this-- so each
one will have a local sum.
And it needs to be
pulled together.
So we have this function called
GAG, which basically takes
associative rays and we'll just
sum them all together, and very
nice tool for doing that.
And, of course, we had to
uncomment that in order
for that to work.
And so let's go give that a try.
And so if we do eval pRUN,
so it's launching them.
And it's reading.
And then now it's going
to have to wait a second.
OK, so it took about two seconds
to pull them all together
and do the sum across
those processors.
So that's a parallel
computation,
a classic example of what
people do with LLGrid
and can do with D4M is
they have a bunch files.
Each processor processes
them independently.
And at the end, they pull
something all together using
this GAG command.
All, right moving on-- so
now I'm on database 2 here.
So I'm going to go to that.
And let's look at our tables.
Very little activity-- and you
see we have no tables there.
So I have to create them.
So I'm going to pd
[INAUDIBLE] setup 05.
That's going to create those
tables on that database.
We can now look, see.
And it created all my tables.
So now I'm ready to go.
And now we're going to
be insert again, PDB06.
I'm going to insert
the adjacency matrix.
And this obviously takes
a little bit longer.
Each one of these, there's
a parameter associated
with the table, which
is-- you would think,
normally, it should
just send all its data
to the database at once.
But it turns out
one thing we found
is that actually
the database prefers
to receive the data in a
smaller increment, typically
around half a megabyte chunk.
So every single time
it's calling this,
it's sending half a megabyte
waiting to get the all clear
again, and then
setting the next one.
And we've actually found that
makes a fairly significant--
so you can see here, we're
getting about 60,000 inserts
per second.
This is from one processor.
And this takes a little while.
Let's see if we can go and
look at it while it's going on.
If we go here, we should
begin to see some.
So there you go.
That's what a real insert
is beginning to look like.
It just changes its axis
for you dynamically here.
But we're getting about
60,000 inserts a second there.
Let me just go along here.
It'll start leveling
off a little bit.
And then it will show you what's
going on in the tables there.
And, I mean, not too
many of you are probably
database aficionados.
But 60,000 inserts a seconds
on a single node database
is pretty darn amazing.
I mean, you would mostly have
had to use a parallel database.
And that's actually one of
the great powers of Accumulo
is there's a lot
of-- even though it's
a parallel database, there's
a lot of problems you can now
do with a single node database
that you would have had to have
a parallel system to do before.
And that's really--
because, parallel computing
is a real pain.
I should know.
If you can make your
parallel problem fast enough
to now work on a
single one, that's
really a tremendously
convenient capability.
So we inserted there, what,
eight million entries-- so
pretty impressive.
But that did take a while.
And so maybe I want to
do that in parallel.
So if I just do eval pRUN, let's
try four and see what happens.
Now I would expect,
actually, this
to begin to top this thing out.
And so the individual
inserts rates on each node
probably go down a little bit.
And you'll see it will get
a little bit noisy here,
because now we have four
separate processes all doing
inserts.
You see there was one.
It took a little
bit, almost a second.
And you get this noise
beginning to happen here.
But we're getting
50,000 edges per second
on one node, which means
we should be getting
close to four times that.
So let's go check.
What's it seeing here?
So if we update that--
and there you see,
we're sort of now climbing
the hill well over 100,000.
That was our first insert there.
And now we're entering
the second one here.
Whoops, don't want
to check my email.
Let's see here.
So how are we doing there?
Oh, it's done.
We may not have even get
the full rise time of that.
Yeah, so it basically finished
before we could even really hit
the-- it has a little filter
here, has a certain resolution.
You really need to do an
insert for about 10 minutes
before you can get
really a sense of that.
But there you see, we probably
got over 200,000 inserts
a second using four
processes on one node.
And we could probably keep
on going up this ramp.
For this data set,
I'd expect we'd
be able to get maybe
500,000 inserts a second
if I kept adding processors
and stuff like that.
And if you look at our
data, what do we got here?
We got like 15 million
entries now in our database.
Again, one of the nice things
is for a typical databases,
a lot of times if you have to
re-ingest the whole database,
that's fine.
In our cyber program,
we have a month of data.
And we can re-ingest
it in a couple hours.
And that's a very powerful
tool to be able to like,
oh, you know what?
I didn't like the ingestion.
That's fine.
I'll just rewrite the
ingestion and redo it.
And this gives you
a very powerful tool
for exploring your data here.
So that's kind of what
I want to do with that.
One of our students here
very generously gave me
some Twitter data.
And so I wanted to show you a
little bit with that Twitter
data, because it's
probably maybe a hair more
meaningful than this abstract
Kronecker graph data.
And by definition, Twitter data
is about the most public data
that one can imagine.
I think no one who
posts to Twitter
is expecting any sense
of privacy there.
So I think we can use that OK.
So let's see here.
Let me exit out of that.
[INAUDIBLE] desktop,
[INAUDIBLE], Twitter.
And so, basically, just a few
examples here-- the first thing
we did is construct
the associative array.
So let's start up here.
And I think it was
like a million Twitter.
Is that right?
A million entries, and how many
tweets do you think that was?
We should be able
to find out, right?
We should be able to find out.
So let's do the
first thing here.
So it's reading these
in, and chunked,
and writing them out
to associative arrays.
That's going to be annoying.
Isn't it?
Let's go to a faster system.
So this is running on
the database system.
And I broke it up
into chunks of 10.
I couldn't quite on my
laptop fit the whole thing
in one associative array.
So I broke it up
into chunks of 10.
Yeah, see we're
still cruising there.
So that just reads it all in.
In fact, we can take
a look at that file.
So I just took that
exact same example
and just put his
data in-- so just
to take a look at
what that involved,
pretty much all the same.
It was one big file.
But I couldn't process it.
I mean, I could read it in.
He did a great job of
creating it into triples.
And I could easily
hold those triples.
But I couldn't quite construct
the associative array.
And so I basically
just go through
and find all the separators,
and then basically take them out
of the vector in memory.
And so that's what I'm doing
here, is I'm looping over here.
So, basically, I
read in all the data.
I find all the separators.
And then I go through.
And it's a little bit
of a messy calculation
to basically do them in
these particular blocks.
And then I can construct
the associative array
and save those out, no problem.
And let's see here.
So what else [INAUDIBLE].
We can do it in little degree
calculation from that data.
So it's now reading
each one of those,
and computing the degrees.
[INAUDIBLE] do the same
thing on this system.
It's pretty fast.
Proceed then to-- let's
create some tables.
So I created a special
class of tables for that.
[INAUDIBLE] modify
that [INAUDIBLE] that.
If you go over here, I
think it was on this one.
Nope, I did it on the other
database-- database 1,
got tables there.
So all I was doing there
was plotting the degree
distribution.
So this shows us--
so, for each tweet--
let's go to figure
one-- are you done?
It's very Twitter-like.
No, no one is ever
done on Twitter.
So-- wow, what did I do?
I went to town, didn't I?
Done now?
So we go to figure 1.
You see for each tweet, this
shows us how much information
was in each tweet.
And you see that, on average--
this is because he basically
parsed out each word uniquely.
So this shows there is about
1,000 pieces of information
associated with each tweet,
which seems a little high.
So we should probably
double check that.
And then what did I do?
So we loaded all of them up.
We summed the degrees.
And then-- oh, I said, show me
all the locations with counts
greater than 100, and then
all the words with at signs
greater than 100, and all
the hashtags greater than 50.
So that's what these
other guys are.
So this was the--
essentially, for each tweet,
how many do you have?
If we go to figure 2, this
shows the degree distribution
of all the words and
other things in there.
So there's some guy here
who is really, really high.
In fact, we can find him out.
But as, of course, most
things occur only once-- like,
there's a lot of unique keys.
There's the message ID, which
of course is probably something
that only appears once.
If we go to figure 3-- so
this just shows the locations.
And this was tweets from the
day before the hurricane,
or the Wednesday
before Hurricane Sandy.
And so this shows us-- but
limited to the New York
area or something like that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, 40 miles
around New York City.
JEREMY KEPNER: 40 miles
Basically, this shows
all the locations here.
So this is a classic
example of the kind
of things you want to do,
because the first thing
that we see is that we have some
problems with our data, which
is New York City and
New York City space got
to go in and correct all those.
So that's a classic example.
This is really what
D4M-- it's the number one
thing that people
do with D4M, is
it's the first time
that you really
can do sums and tallies
over the entire data.
And these things
just don't pop out.
They stick out
like a sore thumb.
Like, oh got to correct that.
You can either correct
it in the database,
or correct it
afterwards in the query.
But that just immediately
improves the quality
of everything else you have.
And then there's this clutter
one, like location none.
Well, clearly, you'd want
to just get rid of that,
or do something with
that, and then just
plain old normal
spelled New York.
So most people can
spell correctly.
And so we're very good.
But location, iPhone,
what's that about?
Jersey City-- well, we
don't care about that.
South Jersey-- well, what's--
South Jersey people don't know
that they're 40 miles
from New York, I guess?
AUDIENCE: It's
whatever they have.
JEREMY KEPNER: In their profile.
So a lot of people in South
Jersey who say they're
from New York.
So what's her name
from Jersey Shore?
Snooki, right Snooki says
she's actually from New York
City, not South Jersey.
So there's a great
example of that.
And then let's see
here, figure 4.
So this just shows
all the at signs.
So you see, basically,
damnitstrue,
is like the most-- is this like
a retweeted thing or something?
I don't know.
What does the at
sign mean again?
AUDIENCE: It's to another user.
JEREMY KEPNER: To a user.
So most people tweet to
damnitstrue in New York.
There you go.
Funny fact, relatable quote,
and then Donald Trump,
the real Donald Trump, and
then just word at sign.
So those are another
example-- another here
is a hilarious idiot,
badgalv, an Marilyn Monroe ID.
So there you go, a lot of
fun stuff there on Twitter.
But this is sort of-- he's going
to establish his background,
and then go back and look
at during the hurricane.
So this is all basically the
normal situation, very clearly.
And then the hashtags-- so
we can look at the hashtags.
So what do we got here?
Favorite movie quotes.
AUDIENCE: Favorite
movie quotes misspelled.
JEREMY KEPNER: And
favorite movie quotes
misspelled right up there.
The Knicks, and then
what I love the most,
and all this type--
team follow back.
I don't know, team auto--
no, what's this one?
What's TFB?
Maybe we don't want to know.
You can always look it
up in Urban Dictionary.
It's a bad one?
All right, OK, good, we'll
will leave it at that,
won't add that to the video.
So continuing on
here, let's see.
Well, you get the idea.
And so all these examples,
they work in parallel to,
you get a lot of speed up, lots
of interesting stuff like that.
But that's very classic
the kind of thing you do.
You get data.
You parse it.
You maybe stick
it in Matlab files
to do your initial
sweep through it.
But then if it gets
really, really big
and you want to do more
detailed things that you
insert in the database,
can do queries there.
Leverage using your counts, so
that you don't accidentally--
you can imagine if we put
all the tweets in the world
and you had location,
New York City.
And you looked at--
you had to, give me
all this set of locations.
And one of them
was New York City.
You'd be like, oh
my God, I've just
done a query that's going to
give me 5% of all the data
back.
That's going to just
flush your system.
But if you can just do
the count, and be like,
oh, New York City has
got a million entries.
Don't touch that one.
Or put an iterator on
that one so that I only
handle it in manageable chunks.
So I want to thank you.
So hopefully this was worth it.
We have one more
class, which deals
with a little bit
of wrapping up some
of the theory on this stuff,
and some stuff on performance
metrics.
And then in two weeks, for
those of you who signed up,
we have the Accumulo folks
coming in showing you
how to run your own
database all day
on just-- we're setting
up a database for you guys
on LLGrid.
But you're definitely going
to run in with your customers
Accumulo instances.
It's good to know some
basics about that,
because a lot of
times you're not
going to have all the nice
stuff that we've provided.
And it's good to know how
to set up your own Accumulo
and interact with
that in the field.
So with that, that brings
the lecture to the end.
And happy to stay for any
questions, if anybody has them.